hey hello everybody and welcome to
another money-making guide today I'm
going to be showing you how I made 1100k
or 1.1 mil an hour of looting from a
chest uh what we were going to need for
this method is 49 agility to get into
the enil agility dungeon and uh 5 to 10
mil starting cash although you can do it
with less just less efficient to do it
that way all right let's get started all
right guys so what we're going to be
doing today is opening up since chests
uh for that obviously you need the
Sinister key now I bought some on the
grand exchange we have 351 that we
boughten uh they took about a day for
these to come through now we B bought
the bulk of them at 29k which you should
still be able to see a offer history
here yeah so we bought 173 or not
actually the bulk but half of them at
29k the other half unfortunately isn't
on here but we bought them at 28200 so
about 800 GP cheaper in total we spent
about 10 mil on the keys 10 mil and
36k and uh what we're going to be doing
obviously is opening the Sinister chest
where that is is just North of
yil and uh what the Sinister chest gives
is noted herbs and it gives the same
thing every time looks like per key I
might be getting between 3 and 4K in
profit off the herbs and they're noted
so you can bring about 20 Keys open them
up and then go back and Bank them and
repeat honestly doing these 350ts really
shouldn't take that long
now there's a couple different ways to
get here uh the most efficient by far
would be going to the Watchtower
teleport unfortunately I don't have that
unlocked but if you do just use a
watchtower teleport 100% it's going to
be the closest way uh next you could use
the fairy ring teleport but between
running between the ring and here I'm
kind of just leaning towards running
back and forth between the bank simple
uh no requirements except for having
this agility shortcut unlocked which I
think is level 20 agility or something
like that it's not very high and uh yeah
that's pretty it guys just going to run
to there run back uh for items you're
going to need you're going to want a
knife because there's a cobweb to cut uh
stamina potion going to run back and
forth you will need a super anti-poison
because are the creatures in there
poison you somehow I'm wearing full
graceful and uh we won't need that
Draymond staff anymore and I won't
really need the glory but we'll keep it
anyway and as far as how many keys
you're going to bring I'm going to bring
20 soz you will need some slots for the
um items to fill into I mean you could
drop them but that's a bit of a pain and
yeah we'll go ahead and meet you in
yanil all right guys so we're in yil uh
so we're at the bank uh right here so
we'll show you the way I'm going to do
it of course like I said use the
Watchtower teleport if you have it
unlocked otherwise you can use this just
the running method it's pretty easy just
run up here and go up to the agility
shortcut which would just be here up to
the
north and just hop under the wall from
here that'll put us pretty much just a
little bit south of the entrance uh
you're just going going to need to slash
the
cobwebs bam now the monsters in here
will attack you unless you are 90 combat
or above I believe um but anyway it's
pretty close all you're going to need is
a few agility levels I believe this
shortcut is you're going to need at
least 50
agility all right from here you're just
going to go through the uh tunnel here
obstacle pipe and that is it that is
where the room with the uh CRA chest is
unfortunately these skeletons are going
to attack me and they do do a reasonable
amount of damage uh because I'm only
wearing the graceful equipment but there
is a decent delay on using the keys so
it's like a 3 or 4 second delay uh but
you can see there we go just pops into
your inventory noted once you get
poisoned make sure to drink a super
anti-poison uh or else um you will just
continue to get poisoned and it'll be no
fun just continue to use the keys guys
you'll get the same loot every single
time uh while time I'm doing a run in
the second here just to see exactly how
much profit per hour you can expect to
get once you've acquired the keys I do
understand getting the keys can be a bit
of a lengthy process but that once you
do have them it looks like we're um
geared to make at least a millon profit
all right guys we'll come back uh once
we've done this run and then we'll do
the rest of them and see how long it's
going to take all right so we're just
finishing up the Run uh probably only
took 3 or 4 minutes in total we'll time
it again more accurately after you might
want to consider bringing a little bit
of food if you're like me me and almost
died from this and anyway just hop back
through the pipe run over the obac
course I make sure just to uh pay
attention to if you got poisoned or not
cuz that can kill you pretty quickly and
right back over and then we're just
going to run out now again the
Watchtower teleport will be much quicker
but this is all I have so don't judge me
too hard and down under the agility
shortcut and back to the bank so what
we're going to do is withdraw 20
Sinister keys and see how much profit
we're going to get per run I'd say maybe
close to 100K uh so mainly you're
getting the profit from the rars uh but
of course the other stuff adds up as
well so we draw another 20 keys and
we'll just do a quick price check for
you so the Sinister Keys we spent about
29k on each uh always bu he saying 580
um and then if we put in all the
herbs uh roughly going to be uh 660 so
that is a well 80k profit per run
considering that only took us probably 3
or 4 minutes we'll say five generously
we'll do a Time rafter but um so 80k
Time
5 I'm doing some weird math here but
anyway looks like it'll be roughly uh a
millon profit now I'm pretty sure it was
quicker than uh 5 minutes so we'll go
ahead finish up these for you and see
how long it takes and get you an
accurate estimate all right so we're
just about to finish up the rest of our
keys uh now I did time to run it looks
like it took about 3 and 1 half minutes
if I was focusing uh so do all of these
Keys took just over an hour um because 3
and a half minutes boils down to about
342 Keys an hour uh if you're kind of
focusing uh you could cut that down
quite a bit more if you use the uh
Watchtower teleport but yeah so we had
351 keys or something like that so it
took a little bit more than an hour but
um if you focusing you could probably
get it down to about an hour and yeah
we're just about to finish up the last
two keys
here and then we'll head back to the
Grand exchange and see how much of this
is actually
worth and uh last key oh my God let me
use the key sometimes you'll click on
the skeletons uh on top of this I
actually did get some uh melee
experience not a whole lot but some and
there we go that was the last key now
we'll teleport back to Edgeville get the
[__] out of
here
and well let's do a little price check
here so again uh we'll bring our notepad
into screen here just so you can see um
we bought 178 of them at uh 28.2k
and sorry 173 at uh 29k so 10 mil and
36k in total if we price check
everything here looks like it's about
11.5 mil roughly which is 1.5 mil in
profit all right so we're back to the
Grand exchange uh we're just going to
instantly sell stuff just because it
doesn't really take or it doesn't really
change the price a whole lot um well
we'll check the prices of rars just in
case there's actually a margin on
them RAR Grand RAR it's only like 23 GP
I'm not going to bother but uh
6993 into yeah I don't think any of
these are going to be a huge
deal oh wait it was little one more
below that and if the price for rars is
higher too you'll also get a better
profit of course and we'll just dump the
rest of the stuff in here and see what
we end up with corms going in there
again you probably could get another 20
30k Profit just by not dumping these but
I'm kind of
lazy and leaves do not seem to be
selling drop these down a little bit
more okay even more damn a it leaves
all right there we go everything is sold
so let's hit the collect button and see
how much we got so we're up to 11 mil
and if we do the uh full price check
here looks like 11.1 mil so we actually
lost quite a bit price checking that or
selling that unfortunately but um yeah
that's about it guys so we got over a
mill in profit from these Sinister Keys
uh probably get closer to 1.3 or 1.4 mil
uh if you uh well I don't think we
actually lost all that money price
checking it or I'm sorry just dumping it
instantly I feel like we most likely
just the prices weren't as high as the
OS buddy guide was saying CU you can see
here let's see we sold the a leaves for
1,000 each uh aventos for
2,000 qums for 2,300 torsos for 4,300
and rear for 6,900 so that's about it
guys I hope you enjoyed the video I
would recommend picking up some Sinister
keys if you get the chance I just leave
an offering for a while and if you pick
up a 100 or 200 you can make a couple
hundred K even up to a m so yeah look
good luck guys and I'll see you guys in
the next
[Music]
video